when you look at your buddy Mad Dog you
mentioned him and you work with him yeah
do you go crazy when you look at a guy's
career like that I mean you saw the
animosity between him and Mike Francesca
I mean I'm not a sports guy but I'm a
broadcaster right and I won two guys
mesh like that and they have a number
one show
why the [ __ ] can't they just get along
what what is the what is that I don't
mean I don't think like that what
happened is this Howard you've been
working together for years
look at what I don't know what the
divorce rate it is in this country but
I'm sure it's over 50 percent I mean you
got people who are married and getting
and getting down between the sheets with
each other that's all of a sudden say I
love you no more I don't want you no
more how you gonna do that and then and
then be surprised that two people who
are arguing with each other for a living
every day ultimately get tired of one
another after 19 years but I will tell
you this
my respect for both is profound
um they are pioneers in this business
and when I brought Mad Dog on my show
first take the bosses didn't think they
could get them I picked up the phone and
called them and in two seconds he was
like I'm there for you uh because I love
the guy and I said this guy and Mike
Francesca started Sports Talk Radio they
made Sports Talk Radio what it is and
guess what else I'm going to do Howard
I'm gonna bring them both in soon
for an appearance on first take on ESPN
oh that's great